>> Tucker: WHEN THOUSANDS OF
BLUE COLLAR WORKERS SHOWED UP IN
OTTAWA SEVERAL WEEKS AGO TO
PROTEST THE TYRANNY BEING
IMPOSED AGAINST THEM, THE PRIME
MINISTER OF CANADA REFUSED TO
MEET WITH THEM OR SPEAK TO THEM.
INSTEAD, HE FLED THE CITY AND
THEN FROM HIS BUNKER, HE CALLED
THE TRUCKERS NAZIS.
WHEN THEY STILL DIDN'T LEAVE THE
CITY, JUSTIN TRUDEAU SUSPENDED
DEMOCRACY AND DECLARED CANADA A
DICTATORSHIP.
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
INVOKED THE EMERGENCIES ACT TO
SUPPLEMENT PRO-VIN SHALL AND
TERRITORYIAL CAPACITY TO ADDRESS
THE BLOCKADES AND OCCUPATIONS.
EMERGENCIES ACT WILL BE USED TO
STRENGTHEN AND SUPPORT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AT ALL
LEVELS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS ABOUT KEEPING CANADIANS
SAFE, PROTECTING PEOPLE'S JOBS
AND RESTORING CONFIDENCE IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
>> Tucker: SO LET'S BE CLEAR.
THIS IS A DEFINING MOMENT IN THE
HISTORY OF CANADA, IN THE
HISTORY OF THE ENGLISH SPEAKING
WEST.
THE EMERGENCIES ACT IS MARTIAL
LAW.
IT HAS NEVER BEEN INVOKED IN THE
HISTORY OF THAT COUNTRY.
NOW, BY LAW, THE EMERGENCIES ACT
IS ALLOWED ONLY IN EMERGENCIES,
IN QUOTE, URGENT AND CRITICAL
SITUATIONS THAT ENDANGER THE
LIVES HEALTH OR SAFETY OF
CANADIANS.
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW DOES NOT
QUALIFY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN CANADA NOW
IS NOT AN EMERGENCY.
HERE'S WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE THIS
WEEKEND.
ACCORDING TO JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
EVERYONE YOU SAW IN THAT TAPE IS
A TERRORIST EVEN THE KIDS IN
THEIR BOUNCEY CAPS.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU REVOKED THEIR
CIVIL LIBERTIES AND AUTHORIZED
MEN WITH WEAPONS TO HAUL THEM TO
JAIL.
TRUDEAU ALLOWED FOR THE ARREST
OF THIS MAN.
>> YOU CAN RECEIVE A FREE MEAL
IRREGARDLESS OF WHAT STATE
YOU'RE FROM, WHAT CREED,
RELIGION.
DOESN'T MATTER.
IT'S ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
KITCHEN.
WE ALL EAT AS ONE AND HUMANITY'S
EQUAL.
SO THE CONCEPT HELPING THE
COMMUNITY IS WHAT WE'RE
PRACTICING HERE TODAY.
WE'RE HERE ALONGSIDE THE
TRUCKERS IN THE FIGHT FOR
FREEDOM AND WE'RE DOING OUR
PART.
>> Tucker: SO AGAIN, ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE CAN NOW BE ARRESTED
ON SIGHT SIMPLY BECAUSE OF WHERE
THEY'RE STANDING.
BEING ARRESTED IS THE LEAST OF
THEIR PROBLEM.
AN ARREST SUGGESTS BAIL, YOU CAN
GET OUT OF JAIL.
YOU CAN'T GET OUT OF THE
COUNTRY, JUSTIN TRUDEAU HAS JUST
MADE.
UNDER MARTIAL LAW, TRUDEAU HAS
THE POWER TO FORCE BANKS TO
SEIZE THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS, AND
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO CANCEL
THEIR INSURANCE.
THAT MEANS THEY CAN'T ACTUALLY
LIVE IN CANADA.
THEY ARE NONPERSON.
THEY ARE ENEMIES OF THE STATE
AND THEY WILL BE CRUSHED.
AT LEAST ONE TRUCKER KNOWS
EXACTLY WHAT'S COMING.
HE HAS SEEN IT BEFORE.
HE CAME TO CANADA FROM ROMANIA.
>> WHY 100 PEOPLE, 180, 200
PEOPLE TO DEFEND YOUR LIVES?
>> UP TO US, TOO, ALL THE PEOPLE
VOTING.
>> WHEN SOME PEOPLE THEY DECIDE
YOUR LIFE.
300 PEOPLE DECIDE YOUR LIFE.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: SO IS IT AN
OVERSTATEMENT TO COMPARING WHAT
HAPPENED IN CANADA TO WHAT
HAPPENED IN A STALIN
DICTATORSHIP.
IN CANADA THEY TALK ABOUT
DIVERSITY.
BUT THE REPRESSION IS SIMILAR.
TODAY CANADA'S DEPUTY PRIME
MINISTER, A FORMER AMERICAN
JOURNALIST, ANNOUNCED THAT GOING
FORWARD, JUSTIN TRUDEAU WILL
REGULATE ALL CROWD FUNDING AND
CRYPTO CURRENCY UNDER THE
TERRORIST FINANCING ACT.
REALLY?
JUSTIN TRUDEAU IS NOW IN CHARGE
OF ALL OF YOUR FINANCES?
HE'S IN CHARGE OF CRYPTO
CURRENCY?
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
HIS GOVERNMENT UNILATERALLY JUST
SENT $1 BILLION TO UKRAINE WHERE
THE HEAD OF THE RIVAL POLITICAL
PARTY IS NOW UNDER ARREST AND
WHERE OPPOSITION MEDIA HAS BEEN
BANNED.
THAT'S THE COUNTRY THEY'RE NOW